alors aucun pays aucun continent n'est
épargné par la crise économique et
financière que nous vivons actuellement
l'inde par exemple qui a connu un
développement considérable ces dernières
années et concerner aussi comme partout
le textile l'automobile et bien sûr la
finance sont touchés y compris le
tourisme
le reportage à bombay la capitale
économique indienne de nos envoyés
spéciaux
il fait 30 degrés à l'ombre
la mer est chaude bombay vit sa
meilleure saison touristique est
d'habitude les hôtels affichent complet
mais aujourd'hui les clients ne se
bousculent pas dans cet établissement de
luxe réflexe de peur sans doute après
les attaques terroristes mais ici on y
voit surtout les effets de la crise
internationale
les indiens qui vivaient à l'étranger
aux états unis en grande bretagne
ils viennent normalement en inde au mois
de décembre en question pour les
vacances des mariages pour des réunions
de famille mais cette année je pense que
ces gens n'ont pas d'argent et la crise
ne touche pas que le tourisme il ya
aussi la métallurgie l'automobile
secteur informatique et le textile
l'une des plus vieilles industries de
bombay nous sommes dans une petite usine
qui fabrique des sacs en coton
biologique dont la moitié pour
l'exportation
aucun des 50 employés n'a encore été
licenciés mais on a supprimé toutes les
heures supplémentaires pour amortir la
baisse des commandes
pour le moment on a réduit la production
de 10% mais très probablement à baisser
de 30% bientôt et on verrait swing % ce
serait une bénédiction
ça devrait descendre encore plus la cote
les autres entreprises de la sont en
grande difficulté est clairement celle
qui ont encore beaucoup d'argent parce
que tout le monde pensait que les
affaires allaient continuer comme ça
indéfiniment
c'est vrai que l'inde a connu plusieurs
années de croissance à 9 % et de profit
exceptionnel au point d'être considéré
comme une future grande puissance à
l'égal de là
sinon alors aujourd'hui le réveil est
quelque peu brutal la bourse de bombay a
chuté de plus de moitié depuis le début
de l'année et la roupie indienne a perdu
10% de sa valeur
de quoi inquiéter les milieux d'affaires
à bombay les salles de marché tourne au
ralenti depuis plusieurs mois en
attendant le retour des capitaux
étrangers
oui on manque d'argent que ce soit dans
la finance ou dans les autres projets
beaucoup de richesses créées grâce aux
capitaux étrangers qu'ils soient venus
car pour aider les entrepreneurs
c'est certain la ddt n'échappera pas à
la crise économique et financière
mais pour en sortir elle sait qu'elle
peut compter sur son marché intérieur
de plus d'un milliard d'habitants new
delhi prévoit même une croissance proche
de 5% en 2009
de quoi faire rêver aux états unis et en
europe